a lot of the discussion around commander
deck building often revolves around the
commander and this makes sense it's
right there in the name of the format in
specific how to best utilize your
command zone is a big area of discussion
and it's certainly one that I've dabbled
in plenty it's good when you can get
more out of a card in your deck that
you'll always have access to however
there's a specific deck building Choice
I've noticed that results from this goal
and it's one that kind of bothers me
that choice is when a player chooses to
take their lovely Synergy engine
commander and turn it into a combo piece
before I go any further I should make it
clear what I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about a player building a combo
deck where the commander is one of the
combo pieces no if that combo is the
deck's primary game plan that's actually
a great way to build a deck utilizing
the Commander in a combo generally makes
that combo more compact which gives
additional deck space for interaction
support cards and alternative game plans
my two best decks involve the commander
being used in a combo for this exact
reason and I'd recommend that to anybody
who's looking for a powerful starting
point for a combo deck what I'm actually
talking about here is a deck where the
primary game plan is something other
than a combo that is focused around the
commander and a combo that involves the
commander is tossed in as an addition to
that on the surface this doesn't seem
like a bad idea you've already got part
of the combo right there and having that
combo might be decent as an alternate
wincon this logic works so long as the
combo isn't significantly better better
than the primary game plan and
especially if the combo pieces also fit
into that plan if I'm building a simut
Beatdown deck combat celebrant and sword
of Hearth and& home are both great cards
for the deck in general and the fact
that they also combo with the haste the
commander provides is just an added
bonus that can allow for explosive wins
on certain board states where things
become a problem is when the combo in
question is one that is out of place and
far more powerful than the next normal
game plan and that is for a couple
reasons
the first is one I've talked about and
alluded to before and this is the lesser
of the two issues in my view The Vibes
issue if you build a deck that's mainly
doing one thing but has some other much
more powerful thing it can draw into 10
to 20% of the time that's going to lead
to some table Whiplash people come into
games with expectations of how their
opponent's decks are going to function
and this is fundamental to any deck
building game that requires skill those
expectations rely on decks following
some sort of logic and when a deck does
a mixture of relatively weak things and
wildly powerful things with no Rhyme or
Reason it's much more difficult for
people playing against that deck to
conceptualize it and strategize around
it if you're looking for a luck based
game with fantas the Aesthetics this
might be a workable situation for you
but on some level it represents a
breakdown of how multiplayer strategy
games work which a lot of players might
not find enjoyable this reason actually
applies to any situation where stronger
and weaker plays coexist regardless of
whether the commander is involved the
other issue with making your command
Commander a combo piece is the much more
tangible one and that's that what you do
with your commander will inform how your
opponents react to that Commander when
I'm playing against a zakara deck and I
have a spare moment to cast a removal
spell the commander is generally going
to be a medium value Target certainly
the ramp it gives is useful and the xell
ability can be quite good if the Zara
player has the right setup to utilize it
but there will still be lots of times
where I'm mostly comfortable with sexa
sticking around for a bit however
according to EDH W 46% of zakara decks
run Freed From The Reel a card that can
produce infinite Mana with Zara's ramp
ability and that's infinite colored Mana
in an X spells deck so the game will
often end right then and there when that
happens if I know my opponent is among
those 46% and I don't want to hold up
mana to remove it later that zakara
immediately becomes a top priority for
removal if I do remove it and they had a
Freed From The Reel in hand well that's
just good defensive play but the other
85% of the time the player probably just
had some hydras and ramp in hand and has
experienced an entirely unnecessary
setback in their goofy mid-range deck
just because they decided to make their
Commander part of an infinite combo this
sucks for everybody involved the hydro
player gets their totally fair Magic
game plan slowed down and a different
player might get to keep a threatening
value engine and pull ahead as another
example let's talk about OT seller of
Secrets now OT is AIG bit different from
daxara in that its combo plan is often
the primary plan while I'd estimate the
number of real freed daxara players who
would consider their deck a genuine
combo deck is pretty low ot's one card
infinite combo with time siiv is the
first thing a lot of people think of
when they think about the commander and
indeed we can see 72% of players are
running this combo however if we dig a
bit deeper we can also see that about
45% of players are playing a OT deck
that is based around voting sorting by
inclusion of bro's representative we can
see that people building this sort of
deck are running lots of voting oriented
cards as well as some Flicker and
artifact synergies seems like a pretty
reasonable midow deck let's say that
it's turn five or six and this sort of
tiot player is casting the commander and
let's also say I'm holding up a counter
spell well tiot is certainly a bit
concerning the card is a strong engine
and him sticking around to get multiple
triggers could lead to the OT player
pulling ahead however there are plenty
of cases where I'd be fine with OT
resolv
especially if there are more opposing
turns before mine what if another
opponent is pulling ahead and I want a
chance at nailing a critical spell of
theirs what if I have a big board I want
to protect from potential board wipes
what if I'm holding up a board wipe and
have the ability to clear out the tiot
later with counter spell backup anyway
in those cases I might just let the
player have their OT and get a bit of
mana and card
Advantage but wait I forgot to mention
63% of voting oriented OT decks run time
Civ sta statistically speaking no shot
that's resolving get your one card
infinite combo deck out of here nerd
once again this tiot player could just
be looking to do fun voting things and
have a grand experiment in mildly rigged
democracy but unfortunately for them
they decided that grand experiment in
democracy also needed a one card
infinite combo so no I think I'll pass
on that one thank you very much this
principle is most pronounced with
infinite combos but it also applies to
other situations where a card radically
changes the nature of what a commander
does take a traxa you can do all sorts
of things with the commander pumping up
plus one plus1 counters loyalty counters
charge counters storage counters and
more and all of these can work alongside
each other just fine well all except for
one the second you throw some poison
counters on your opponents the commander
immediately reads each turn I get a
poison counter for all your opponents
and their removal choices will reflect
that oh you were hoping to do some funny
super thrs things with the traxa now no
not even worse since poison counters are
almost impossible to remove there's a
certain terrifying inevitability that's
present even if a track that isn't in
play currently the fact that she could
be in the future will likely serve as
enough of a threat to Warrant some very
focused rounds of attacks to fully put
on my social theorizing hat a big part
of casual EDH is figuring out ways to
win that your opponents will allow you
to perform the setup for examples of
this might consist of getting a large
land count before casting a massive
spell getting getting a board of tokens
before playing an overrun effect setting
up some Synergy pieces before landing a
centerpiece card that will allow the
deck to Surge out of control and so on
by contrast poison counter proliferation
is about as visible and visceral as
setup gets your opponents will be
kicking and screaming against the
lurching inevitability of your game plan
even when it's no stronger on paper than
doing a good old-fashioned tokens plus
overrun that's not to say that poison
counters are never a valid win plan but
you need to know what you're getting
yourself into at the end of the day
that's the main thing that all of this
really comes down to knowing what kind
of magic you want to be playing if your
commander is serving one purpose for
your deck stretching it to fill more
roles can be a great way to up your
overall efficiency and consistency but
you do need to keep an eye on what
exactly those roles are and whether they
pose dramatically different threats to
your opponents in my R deck the
commander serves two primary purposes
being a
creatures this works well because
neither of these purposes step on each
other's toes removing the commander
early to cut me on Mana isn't a set back
to the lieutenant creatures because I
haven't played any yet and removing the
commander as a lieutenant enabler isn't
a major step back to Mana generation
because having r as a manad dor isn't
that important past turn four anyway it
is also possible to have your commander
perform roles that conflict in some way
and having that work out just comes back
to once again knowing what kind of magic
you want to play in my strongest deck
Malcolm is both a combo piece and a Mana
engine this frequently renders him the
scariest creature on board and also
means that him eating a removal spell is
a pretty major setback I account for
this by running a massive pile of
counter spells that I can cast using the
treasures malcol generates I know
exactly how my opponents are going to be
feeling and I'm prepared to say no if
they send their removal spells in the
most logical Direction I also made the
deck as consistent as possible at
getting time siiv out because my
opponents are going to be bracing for it
anyway and how they treat Malcolm so I
may as well make sure the effort I spend
defending Malcolm isn't in service of
some janky pirate Beatdown when it comes
down to it I'm not trying to give any
hard and fast rules here I'm just trying
to make sure that players have their
expectations well calibrated if you're
prepared to fight ruthlessly to keep
your commander in play that's great and
I wish you all the luck in the world in
that battle on the contrary if you're
just here for a good time and don't want
to fight that battle don't build your
deck in a way that gives other people
extra reasons to kill your stuff